both teams wearing number 42 tonight
in commemoration of jackie robinson and
now kevin newman
newman hitting 259 the pitch
bouncing ball toward third and throwing
to the plate
and getting gonzales in a rundown back
to soulguard and the
catcher will tag gonzales who stays in
the rundown
long enough to allow tucker to go to
third and newman who hit the ball to
wind up at second
we'll see what ends up happening if josh
belton comes through
to base it bring in a couple this ball
is lined toward right
and this should bring home the run jace
peterson will make the catch
sacrifice fly will make it one nothing
as
tucker scores newman to third and bell
picks up rbi number 11 on the year
here at the bottom of the first and here
comes christian yelich in little early
work rock rock as you mentioned here
today
you can see the baseballs down in the uh
right-handers batter's box talking about
you know the stance
maybe christian a little bit too narrow
a little bit too wide he's going to line
his feet up with those baseballs and
then
go with his normal approach you know how
i wish that guys would throw me
underhand when i played
[Applause]
and there's a fly ball he's back in a
deep right field
there it goes payne's magic underway at
miller park
how about that way to go andy
i'll tell you why the gun has been
grinding andy haynes the blue is hitting
coach i mean the extra work you see
where that ball landed
be honest i lost it yeah that ball just
crushed it over the second deck and
right
here's ryan reynolds and a ground ball
up the middle diving
stop oh my goodness they get one and the
turn not in time orlando arcia
oh that's beautiful wow what a play heck
of a play by
orlando arceum with a diving stab urias
was there to take a throw at second base
for the force that's all they get
good play by orlando arceum so there are
two men out bases remain
loaded as we go back to the top of the
order and now here's urias
full count brewers everywhere the 3-2
and a run is in as maria's works her
walk
2-1 for stallings
the highest batting average in the month
of august throughout all the baseball is
jacob stallings
and the pitch to him breaking ball and a
line drive hit pretty deep toward right
center field that's going to split the
gap
and jacob stallings is going to wind up
at second base with a stand-up rbi
double that ties the game at two
is jose ozuna
[Applause]
back up the middle oh nice stop aureus
that looks like that might eat him up
maria says i got this
i did eat him up with the glove unable
to save him that's a heck of a play by
boy those are good hands right there
check this out this ball is hit hard
ozuna
pounds it look at the top spin on it
able to
flag it down and make the throw so
gonzales at third with one out in the
batter is kevin newman with the infield
in
that will be deep enough
here comes gonzalez trotting home the
pirates
in the lead three to two made it look
easy i just get a sac
five let's just knock this out to center
field two outs
run in bell a sacrifice fly and a ground
down bell will bat with the bases empty
and they'll still be empty after this
one over the wall for a home run
josh bell with his third home run of the
year
sends it out to center and the bucks go
up two
and ring your bell for josh bell it's
his third
of the season and gives the pirates a
4-2 lead in the fifth
and we've got a giant eagle winner chris
stratton the new pitcher for the
pittsburgh pirates
they'll face orlando argentina to start
throws a little
of everything there's a drive off the
battle varsity in the left center field
and that is gone
and a home run solo shot orlando arcia
as the brewers pull to within a run
well he laid the wood on that baby good
swing on that pitch
from orlando aren't you with two strikes
his second home run of the season it's
4-3
pirates leaning 4-3 were in the eighth
inning
and it's two balls no strikes and yelich
is shot into right field and that's down
a base hit
and he takes the turn at first and he'll
cruise into second
with a double of the lead off the eighth
that's when you know yellows are
starting to figure it out when a lefty
is that on the mound and he hits a
bullet like that into right field
the the brewers are in business now
abbas
garcia is going to bat for ben gamble
i guess that would be called a game face
235 and if that isn't the look of
determination i don't know what is
runners lead and turning sucks one into
the count
and hits sharply fair ball down the line
here comes
[Applause]
garcia shoots one down the line
garcia hit a frozen rope inside the line
at third
it scored two he's going to wind up with
a double
someone's got to get a hit against this
guy he's got to give up the hit
eventually
he has faced 34 batters zero
have a hit here's the 3-1 up high ball
four and that was close to being a
strike here's the 3-1
that's way outside and high and it's
ball four he's walked two of the three
batters he's faced
the pitch way high he walked him and
he's walked the bases loaded
3-0 to stallings and that one's wide
and the pirates tie it on four walks
from josh hader
three and oh here's the stretch the
pitch
ball four he walked him the pirates lead
it
six to five as josh hader
has walked in two straight runs the lead
off
batter for the crew on and eric sogard
the batter
2-1 pitch and there's a fly ball hit
back into right field
it's deep it is
[Applause]